we have um
austin and jeremy here with us today
and i'm all i'm saying welcome to pi
data
and my name is kip sata and i'll be
happy to be um
to be hosting this session today
so um i'm going to invite jeremy and
austin to share the screen and um
but before then i'm going to introduce
them austin is currently a machine
learning engineer
manager and also a researcher focused on
nlp natural language processing and
automated
machine learning
well jeremy also uh is
did his doctoral
doctoral studies at the university of
illinois
where he worked on improving medical
diagnostic techniques through computer
vision and
optimization techniques
since 2017 he's been with capital one
where he's working on machine learning
optimization infrastructure nlp
model development such as sensitive data
leveler within the data provider and
their engineering design
behind the open source library data
provider which they are going to talk
about today in that
in their talk so welcome austin and
jeremy and we are happy to
hear your talk
hello everybody so
um this talks primarily as we mentioned
about the data profiler um it was
developed uh at the university of
illinois uh campus offices
and applied research at capital one
um here's the main developers that we um
are currently working with so it's
myself um
austin jeremy grant and chris uh grant
and chris are currently in san francisco
um so first let's kind of set the ground
rules what is data profiling so it's the
process of examining data
available from existing information
sources so you can think of a database
or a file and collecting statistics or
informative summaries about that data
and this
typically helps you take actions of some
kind
um so our goal was to point at any file
um regardless of the file type and
obtain insights
for engineering security and data
science and then
in terms of what they might look like we
might want to get things like schema
data labels distributions the encoding
of the file things like that
um some of the major use cases that we
were tackling um with this project was
um
sensitive data detection so you can
think of like a phone number uh social
security number things like that might
be in a file we need to be able to
identify it um as we're a bank um that
can often be pretty important
um
additionally we want to look at schema
identification so sometimes downstream
downstream systems if a schema changes
we'll have a failure of some kind
so we're using the data profiler to
basically use machine learning and
statistics to identify if the schema
changes
maybe columns flip things like that
and then we're also trying to track uh
profiles over time um so sometimes the
underlying data set can change in such a
way that it causes downstream failures
um so we're using the data profiler to
effectively uh identify how data sets
change
um
so kind of what we wanted to do is make
it as simple as possible
so a lot of times if you're like a data
scientist or software engineer you spend
a lot of time trying to format the data
or load it in the particular way that's
useful typically you have kind of a
standard format
so if you're using a machine learning
model you know you're going to want it
to be in like
a similar structure every time something
like a pandas data frame
so what we want to do is load any data
source um with a single command um
and then format it in such a way that we
can
do calculations on that data
so we wanted to load the data with one
command calculate the data uh profile
with one command and we might calculate
things like again
encoding schema data types labels
distributions the number on nulls and
the goal is really to do this through
sampling the data as opposed to maybe
doing the whole data set
and also do it in bigger than run time
so basically one pass
the reason being is if it's something
like n squared or something like that
it's going to
um be extremely costly as we're doing
this at scale sometimes with you know
terabytes or petabytes of data
and then once we
do that we want to be able to display
update or save a profile with one
command
i would say in addition to that you
might want to
look at
maybe distributing how you calculate
profiles and we'll kind of get into what
we do there um but the end result is
obviously just calculating a profile and
showing it to you once isn't necessarily
the only thing you want to do since we
also want to track it over time
so we need to be able to save and update
profiles
so we tried to do that make the api
really as simple as possible
so
as you can see if you load the data
profiler
basically it's a single class that you
call and if you pass in a file name it
could be like a csv file an avro
really any like the limited delimited
file parquet json
you actually can
retrieve what we call a data class out
of it so it automatically
determines
what that file type is kind of
regardless
of the extension that's provided it'll
go into the file sample it and determine
what the file is and then load the data
into
a class that also has a pandas
compatible data frame
and then in addition to that you can
then pass that data class into our
profiler and you can calculate the
statistics and do entity recognition
things like that
and then easily generate a report now
the report is in json format there are
some graphs and some other things we can
generate um we're going to kind of go
into that a little bit later in the
presentation
in addition to that we also have the
options of updating emerging profiles so
if you think of a again like you might
want to you might have a data set split
into two csvs for instance
so say file a file b
you're going to want to be able to load
both those data sets profile both those
data sets and then merge them together
into a single profile
so our library allows us to do that
um we can also save or pickle basically
pick a profile and then load it later
and then addition to that we also have
the ability to look at the differences
between profiles so say we have two data
sets one from
a month ago and one from today we can
actually load
both data sets profile both data sets
and then actually look at a difference
between the two so you can see if like
which data is potentially shifting
particularly that's interesting if like
the distributions in the given column
are changing
um
for like neural networks or things like
that that can actually for you know
provide some insight as to why your
model might be failing
so that's like the brief overview what
we're going to do now is actually go
into um jupiter notebooks and kind of
show you guys how it works so if you
want to do it yourself and follow along
you're welcome to do that
so you it's this is on pipeline so you
can just do pip install data profiler
full dash user
um we have different versions if you
want um like the machine learning
components versus not having the machine
learning components
full lets you
install everything at once
um and then if you also want to
follow along in the examples you can do
git clone and then
basically i think i provide that in the
chat
and then you just go to the examples
folder so i'm going to take a brief
moment to do that and i'm going to also
post in chat again
just in case anyone else
joined and while we do that
i'm going to answer a question by brian
can you do
weighting in the sampling method
um
i don't believe we can at the moment but
if you want to add an issue we can um
you can change the amount of sample like
amount of sampling you do um
so for instance you can say i only want
to sample 10 percent of the data set
versus a
say 30 of the data set you could do
stuff like that but i don't think you
can do weighted sampling at the moment
right there i'd also like to kind of dig
into that question a little bit brian if
you have a moment in terms of weighted
sampling are you talking about labeling
specifically or are you talking about
weighting different samples for getting
like a statistical profile of the data
set
that's an interesting question
and i also well while we're waiting for
that i also want to point out uh we
didn't completely you know introduce it
but at the end of the present or at the
end of the training we will go into data
labeling which is a super hot topic
right now for which incorporates our
natural language processing where we're
looking at either structured or
unstructured text and trying to predict
what that text is
whether it's you know something that
represents someone's social security
number or a phone number or what have
you
and so we'll go into that in the
modeling and how you guys can utilize
that or develop your own models to
incorporate inside the library itself
um if you guys have any questions feel
free to just put them in chat and while
i'm talking jeremy can answer or vice
versa while jeremy's talking i can
answer
um so i'm going to keep going i put in
chat where you can get to the tutorial
notebooks and i'm just going to continue
on so
the first topic we're actually going to
discuss is what we call the data readers
or how you load the data um so
if you were uh recall we've the first
thing we do is we load
uh the data and this can be you know
some sort of delimited data avro parquet
json
data
and basically the idea is you should be
able to ingest ideally anything but
right now we're limited to a few
different data like formats um
we also allow users to specify options
so you might have like a format a header
delimiter
the coil character things like that that
you can help the system
typically the system identifies
everything pretty accurately on its own
we haven't really had any major issues
but you can also override it with the
options
and then the idea is the final thing we
want to do is streamline the capability
so
uh compatibility so what we're trying to
do is load all these different data
types into a single object that we can
then
use our profiler on
so it's
it's a pretty uh
challenging task
so in terms of an example so this is
actually
a guide i had from kovid
with my kids so
we had activity sheet what we would do
every day at a given time
uh my kids are a little bit young so you
see we're playing with play-doh
potty breaks things like that and i
actually we added at as the delimiter
symbol we know to note that the um
the actual header is on the second line
of this this file
and all you have to do is do dp which we
would you know when we do import data
profile we do
we import it as dp and then we do dot
data and
the path to the csv in this case it's a
at symbol
and
it formats it correctly identifies where
the header is identifies the delimiter
it identifies the quote character and
basically it's able to load it in a
structured way that we can then profile
and that's uh
i shouldn't say csv example but it's a
delimited example
similarly we have a nested json example
here where we have
some metadata and then we have a payload
and then in this case is octopus and
it's like blue ringed octopus giant
octopus you know um it has different
features of it
and what we do is we actually load it
all into uh this is broken up but this
is a this would be a single
table basically so you'd have
payload.octopus.bluering.name
and it would have all the data
associated with this
in a given table so it's a single tape
data table
that's compatible with pandas that
allows you to do most of the the same
functionality that pandas has
so
that's the the brief overview and i'm
going to go into the notebook and kind
of go through exactly
what that looks like
so if for those who are following along
you can go in data profiler
and then you can go to examples
and then the current one we'll be
working off of is the data readers
python notebook
um our jupiter notebook
so the
base case for the data profiler actually
is
you have a single command called data
but it's a factory class which will
actually
load one of these different classes
right so you have csv data which is
actually delimited
kind of like any delimited data will be
mapped into here so you'll have csv tsv
i don't know what app the yacht simple
one would be
but basically they all get loaded into
this delimited data
class you have the json data class the
parquet data class avro data class and
text of the class the text data would be
unstructured data um and then we
actually have a different profiler for
that which we'll kind of cover later um
but if basically if none of these work
it'll be mapped to the text data class
and we'll just treat it as text data so
you won't be able to get like rows and
columns for instance but you can still
read the data
each of these classes can be used
individually so if you just want to load
something directly into the csv data
class you can
however
if you want to use our auto detection
capability um basically you could just
do dp.data and then the path and even if
it has the wrong
extension it'll figure it out
um so i already re-ran like ran
everything ahead of time just to make it
make sure it all worked
um
so if you look at the
kind of like the the different things
we're going to go through here
we have the data reader
and we're going to read a bunch of
different uh data sets
from data profiler
data
and
we're going to have a few different uh
csv files um you might know if you want
to pull up some of these you can
um so i'm going to pull up
a couple real quick
um
so if we look at the
say the the
csv
and then we look at the
which one is this the skip header
so you can see that we we don't have
so this is kind of what the file looks
like right here um
so we don't have a header right here
there's also ones where you have partial
headers so
um where we'll have like blog posts date
comma comma
um so the entire header would not be
there
um we also have ones where there's
quotes basically there's a bunch of
different things that we're
um
trying out here to kind of show like
showcase all the different ways we do
the automatic detection
we also have the one where you'll have a
sparse first and last an empty column
let's see where that one is so that
one's kind of
so you'll have something that looks like
this where you'll have a empty row up
top and then you'll just have random
stuff and we want to see if this can
detect whether or not this is a comma
delimited
file basically
similarly we have parquet files that are
mislabeled
essentially we just mislabeled as much
as we could and made it as complicated
as we could for the
profiler
and
if you run this little snippet code
right here the second cell you'll see
that it correctly identifies all the csv
it correctly identifies all the json
even if they're mislabeled
parquet avron text
and then we also have this cool ability
where you can just directly add urls
so
if you just
throw in
the like one of the the urls to the
github data for instance
you can it'll automatically load for you
so this
can be useful if you're just testing
things out really quick
now in addition to that um we also have
options so typically we allow options um
in case the user knows their data format
ahead of time or they want to map
something to a particular class
so for instance say we have this panda
data frame right here
and we know
um that we want to map this into the csv
data object for some reason
you can actually just say the data type
dot cs or data type equals csv
and it will produce the
that that data class for you um
similarly uh you can also directly just
load from the csv data class itself and
just put data equals data frame um
there could be some reasons for this i
know like in one of our the applications
we were checking the data type to see if
it was a csv data or not um and then
just logging in the back end um so
um you could do it for things like that
uh all the options are listed on the
um
i want to click that but basically on
the data reader uh documentation
if you're interested in the
documentation
it's right over here
on the github page
in addition to all that
the data
we basically keep different attributes
in the data class so we'll actually
identify the encoding for you so
sometimes you have utf-8 etf 16 ascii
that can be useful for machine learning
models or determined compatibility
so if you take this ews honeypot marks
geo
and you run it in through the data
profile or the when you load it via the
data class
um we identify as a csv we'll keep track
of where the file is located the file
encoding uh we'll also identify
the um
the length of the data
and then if you want to just check out
the data you can do data.data
so one of the cool things about this is
basically data is the data class and
then
the data would be the pandas data frame
and you could do you know
data.data.head data.data.sort
you can sort the data there's a bunch of
things you can do with that
so
i'm not gonna do that right there and
then the
we also have
other items um which can check the file
type so you have is match so this is how
we're doing the internal
um
detection basically of whether or not a
given
data set
matches a class so
if we want to check if something is a
delimited data type we could use
csv.data.ismatch
and it will identify it for you so
in this case for instance we have all
the files we had before
that are
labeled as csv files but not really csv
files and we say csv is match dot or csv
data dot is match and we give it the
file path
and it will let us know whether or not
that's a csv data so as you can see here
all the csv
gets labeled as such and all the non-csv
does returns false because it's not csv
data
um
i'm gonna i guess stop here and see if
we have any questions um
about any of this because i know i'm
just kind of going through it and no one
likes being talked out so does anyone
have any questions that we can answer
while we're also waiting on those
questions um
i want to put this in perspective in
terms of like a story in the sense that
if you as a user have a large corpus of
data right and you don't know what that
data is and you don't want to manually
have to go through and
specify how to read every single type of
file expecting them to all be curated
correctly and labeled properly
that's the purpose of this class
essentially is so that way no matter
what the file is or where it came from
or what it is existing as you can use a
simple command to just load any data
type and if it's structured data it'll
load it in a format that we can read it
as structured data if it's unstructured
data we're going to load it for you in a
format that can be read as unstructured
and then of course it just simply gets
pushed into the profiler which you're
going to see next
but that's the overall intent of this we
want to be able to essentially like oh
we at some point we want to be able to
add you know the ability to just read
straight from s3 um
i i mean you're going to see i mean if
you haven't seen you're going to see
that you know we can just load straight
from a url at this point so s3 is just a
step away right
and so just to be able to scan any
repository of data and load it freely
without having to consider how to do
that has been really helpful for us
um
so yeah as someone asked we can profile
unstructured data uh yes we can it's
you're not gonna get all the same
results but we'll cover that a little
bit later in the presentation
um
yeah so to put it into perspective i
think um in addition to kind of what
jeremy was pointing out um basically one
of the use cases for this is we have
petabytes of data in capital one a lot
of times people are throwing files in
random s3 buckets doing you know some
sort of data science work and we want to
also ensure that there's no sensitive
data in those files so we need a way to
basically scan all the data all the time
anytime it lands in any kind of bucket
or anything and see if there's any
sensitive data in there but also
determine like which data sets are
probably more related to one another um
and see like maybe one data set comes
from another so that's kind of like the
the upper level use case for this
we end up using it for a lot of our work
though just because it also formats
things for neural networks and whatnot
quite nicely so
with that in mind i also want to point
out you can technically
do reloading
so if you have the original data
and you want to reload it
and maybe reload it into like records
samples per line
you can do that
so basically we allow
people to format the data in different
ways if you wish
um that is pretty well described in the
api documents so i'm not going to go
through
it's a ton here but you might want to do
this for things like
again for training a neural network
things like that
you might want to format your data
slightly differently so we basically
allow that option
uh and now we're going to dive a little
bit into just the csv data reader um so
each one of these readers are going to
have slightly different components and
the reason being is
if you as i'm sure you can imagine you
know json loading json data is pretty
dramatically different than loading um
delimited data
um and one of the coolest things we
think is the ability to automatically
detect
everything um without having to worry
about kind of what it you know what the
underlying stuff is so you don't have to
like inspect the file yourself
at least too often
um so one of the things um you can do
is you can load the class directly as we
kind of mentioned before
so rather than doing dp.data file path
you do csv data file path
and when you do that you can use things
like head so you can basically see what
the
so this loads each of these three files
and then shows you uh you know the head
of each
um you could also add the options so the
csv data class um as you can imagine
uh sometimes you're gonna need to like
or maybe not sometimes but um you're
gonna need to
potentially specify the delimiter the
quote character sometimes you want to
say like the header is on which a given
line so say
you have a big
csv file and the header is actually on
line 200 or row 200
um you might have to specify that
we have a
setting called auto which will try to
detect it
but if you have something that's really
crazy it might not be able to
and then we also determine the data
format um so
so you can basically return things as a
string or as a
data frame or a record
so records were kind of described before
so it'll be
something that looks kind of like this
it's just like a list
a data frame
is basically a pandas data frame
and then you could also select given
columns so we use this if we want to do
like sub sampling for instance you might
want to say um i only want to look at
column a and b
um because you're using that in your
neural network um or your machine
learning model are you doing some sort
of linear regression you don't care
about the rest of it you can actually
just select the given columns um again
you'd have to know that ahead of time so
but you could
so
in this case we're going to load the
daily active sheet at with single quotes
um basically the
sheet kind of looks like this
and when we load it we can actually
um the data class you can say
data.delimiter
and it will tell you the delimiter
that's in that file and
data.quotecharacter and then i'll tell
you like where character was detected in
that file
um and then you could also obviously do
data.data.head
um technically you can
go ahead yeah i was gonna
interrupt there awesome because i think
you're about to hit on that point so one
of the neat features that we also added
was the ability to if you want to delete
that second data dot um we did include a
wrapper so that way if the depending on
the underlying data class you can apply
the functions inherent to the how the
data was loaded to just our original
data object so if austin you want to
delete one of those data that data's
next to the head
to the left of it yeah
and he applies that we are basically
looking at all of the um
we're looking at the function since it
was loaded as a pain as data frame we
look at the functions that we could
apply to the pandas data frame instead
and if you want to apply that or you
want to do slicing or indexing or so
forth to that data set via the functions
we allow you to do that directly so you
don't have to call data.data every time
you can apply the functions provided you
know it's not something we've
technically overridden with our data
class
yep
similarly uh you can actually set the
options um
so we just set the same options because
that's what it's supposed to be
but you can manually set the options as
well so this is useful if we have a file
that
for some reason can't be loaded um
currently our thing seems to load or the
system seems to load relatively well so
we don't really have
too many times like the auto
fails um
but if it for some reason it does you
can you can switch stuff out
um and then
here's a one where we intentionally um
cause a failure with incorrect options
um so
take the same file and we say
that the delimiter is a comma and the
code character is a you know just a
double quote
um if you try to load the data you're
going to get something that looks kind
of like this
and it'll say when data type
sets a csv it fell over to text data so
basically what ends up happening is
because those options are being set in
that particular way
um i believe
can we do this journey
it'll fail over to the text basically
so
um
you know essentially we gave it these
options we said this is the delimiter
and this is the quote character the
system failed because it's in it's not
using the correct data
and
and so you're gonna end up getting um
basically different data set there you
go so
uh it basically fails over to text and
if you if you want to see kind of what
it looks like you can still technically
access all the data but it's just not in
a formatted way
um in addition to kind of that stuff
does anyone have any questions
all right
um
i'm going to continue on then
um so in addition to kind of that
uh those options you can also set the
header
so some of the more complicated files we
have in our test set um one looks like
this so it's author austin walter then
it has a couple like lines of
description followed by the actual
header um so detecting that like is a
little bit difficult
but
the system's able to handle it
um in this particular case
um
so essentially it goes through and
identifies the the first time it starts
seeing a pattern and it sees a pattern
with the commas and the three columns so
it's able to pick that up and skip the
first few
um
you could also intentionally set
the header so i intentionally set it to
the wrong
the wrong row so i put it as row two
um and you can see that you have this
description up here which is what it
ends up grabbing um when in reality it's
supposed to start down below
um so it looks at each of these as a
single column at that point
um
let's see what else so
and this is where we kind of covered the
differences between the data formats so
the data formats will load so the data
frame um basically loads everything as a
data pin as data frame
we also have records
so in terms of records they will load
everything as
you can do record samples per line
so that's how many rows are combined
into a single line
this is useful if you're doing something
like uh
particularly for neural network training
where you might want to
take
just like maximize your throughput
through a gpu
for instance so you're going to want to
basically flatten part of your data set
so as you can see we take the
diamonds.csv
here's the first few lines that
and then we can actually flatten it to
the record samples per line
so just for the heck of it i'm going to
do two
and
you can see that it it'll generate
um
right to there
um
yeah
so
in terms of kind of like what it's hard
to see with the
thing but basically it takes these two
rows and we'll flatten them into a
single
entry
if that makes sense
so you have row one
slash n row two
then you have row three slash n row four
and so on
um so you can basically feed that into
your gpu
um is the primary use case for it and
you can have the entire uh kind of like
um
gpu maximized
and i think we're nearing the end of
this but basically the next one is you
can also select columns
so say we try to load the aws honeypot
marks geo.csv dataset which has a bunch
of different columns in it
so you have longitude latitude owner
comma daytime host source things like
that it's basically just
logs
for routing
say we only want to select the date time
host and source you just say selected
columns
and then you can pass it into the data
along with the file path
and you can get
the given columns
so this is kind of the end of the
this particular section
for those that are curious
who are just joining us
you want to follow along
here's the
chat we are using this repository
and we are going through the different
examples
um the example notebooks
is if you want to install it yourself
you can just do pip install data
profiler phone
easy on everybody
cool
um so does anyone have any questions on
the data reader section that wants to
speak up or you can post some chat and
i'll read them aloud
if you are on a mac using zsh you will
have to put quotes around data profile
error
all the way to the end for full when you
use the square brackets
just so you know
alrighty um jeremy do you want to
take over from here
yep i am good to go
all right
uh
i think austin you can see the screen i
assume if you can see what everyone else
can yep
yeah um so now we get kind of a little
bit more fun uh obviously data rating is
really important and be able to automate
that system uh
opens up a lot of avenues uh
specifically for either profiling or
data labeling just like i said before to
be able to scan a repository with no
known
idea of what's inside of it and to get
information out can be critical
so we're going to go over the specific
aspects of the profiling library uh
first
component is just generating so if we
focus on structured data we're gonna
generate information about each column
within the data set uh we're gonna do
simple statistics like min max mean
histogram we're going to get more
complicated by determining whether like
the data sets categorical is there order
of the data set like ascending
descending um we're going to look at uh
some some more complicated statistical
properties like jenny impurity or
unlikability
so we've we've added a lot of components
and a lot of that has been feedback from
our users users and what they're looking
for um and some of the other like neat
aspects of it
that was kind of
uh slowly or
introduced slyly was the fact you know
we can do something like profiler
differences where you can take a data
set and take a second one and try and
figure out what's different between them
like why is you know if you're training
on if you're talking about neural
networks or models if you're training on
a one data set and then
you're doing validation with a second
data set because you've split it but the
results are really off you could you
know take the the differences between
the profiles of the data sets to try and
you know inspect or understand what's
happening or what are the differences or
changes between that data sets that
might be impacting your model
or or for instance you know you had
you've developed an api uh on a specific
data set and you're getting a new data
set and you're logging that information
and you want to know you know what is
what is
why is the api
not working as expected um then you can
look at you know obviously the
difference between you know how you
specced out your api in one data set and
then decide and then what you're
actually getting or that can just give
you information of how you need to
update your api
um
and so we generate column level
statistics and structured we generate
global statistics and structured and
then we want to give everyone an easy
way to understand what's in it so we
output a report um
with
we want to at some point make it an html
report
right now it's
basically a json report that's printed
out but also we allow graphing feature
so this is what the report looks like
and just in case i'm going to pull up my
chat in case anyone asks questions
while we're going through this
um
right so this is what a structured
report looks like and this is uh not
even the full list of
of
of elements that we have within our data
stats so we have a component that's
global stats we have a component that's
data stats and you'll see something that
calls times
times essentially we want to record how
long it takes each component so that way
you know i mean i'll talk about options
once again readers have options
profilers have options reports have
options we want to give the user as much
customizability as they can for when
they're using this product
um
but we do that because like especially
like giving information about the times
it's because not every user needs every
component or every statistic given by
the library and we want to give the
users the flexibility to turn that stuff
on or off and the ability to reduce the
computational cost of each aspect of the
library if they don't need something
like many users maybe just need labeling
and they want to know what the labels of
each column are in the data set or maybe
they just want to know simple features
or like a histogram of the data set and
so they can turn off everything else if
they want to
and so we tried to make that really
simple with our options um but always
always improving right you never can do
it best you know the first couple times
uh always iterating on that
um and so i kind of just talked about
options you can turn stuff on or off uh
and then in that report you're going to
get a more simplified view of what's
going on
and because i don't want to spend too
many too much time on slides
jump straight into the demo once again
this is a repo
one
github.com
data profiler we'll be in examples and
we're going to go through the structured
profiler and then after that we'll get
into the unstructured profiler too
and again if anyone has questions please
put that in chat or chime in um happy to
answer that while we go through austin
is happy to answer that on the fly so
please don't hesitate to let us know
what's going on
okay
so circuit profiling i'm going to gloss
over this uh just because we know
uh i mean we went through the slides we
talked a little about what this means
um some stuff we didn't talk about was
like the options when we do our reports
like this we give the users different
you know abilities to make the
output more readable like in a terminal
uh or the output more readable in terms
of like limiting all like maybe
unnecessary features by making things a
bit more compact um
and then obviously we want everything to
be serializable so that someone can save
the report and uh open it up elsewhere
so we save it as a json if that's
desirable um and then in some situations
like saving to a database for instance
that database may not be able to take a
nested structure
so we do have the ability to flatten the
information that comes out of this
report so that can be saved
accordingly
so i'm going to jump right in here
i'm just going to run this
and hopefully some of this doesn't take
too long um basically just importing the
library as you would expect
we've already learned how easy it is to
load data
so all i did here was load the csv data
set
for the aws honeypot
one command to profile that data set one
command to report it and then i can
print it out
and so obviously we have logging logging
again we've we had a user ask uh us to
disable that so if you want to and the
the print out of tux gets uh is not
something you desire we do have the
ability to turn off the logging features
of the library
so like you see here we have global
stats here
it tells us how many samples were in the
data set how many columns are the row
count very simple basic stuff
we're looking at hashing between rows to
determine whether a row itself is unique
across the whole data set how many
duplicate rows there are if we were to
find that
tell you about the file type that was
loaded
what the file contents looks like in
terms of its encoding
um we have information like um
this is nan probably because of
uh just what the data set was it wasn't
able to do a chi-squared matrix and
that's okay
we give you the schema of the data set
so
we are able at this point to handle
duplicate columns so if you have a data
set that you load that has two names
that are potentially date time we will
give you a list of the indices of where
those date time columns exist or where
that labor label or that header for that
column exists
so we are able to handle duplicate
columns which is an uh could be a
complicated feature otherwise if you're
not expecting that
scroll past that so obviously it tells
you how long it took to uh
do those row statistics
and then we get a lot of a little bit
interesting or a little bit more
interesting information here um
so we get a data label that's using our
data labeler and it's looking at this
column date time and determine those
date times in here it also determined
there may be floats that exist somewhere
in this data set
and so that could just be based on uh
the representation so we might have
different representations of date time
that and these are the samples that it
pulled out from this data set
um
and it so it can give you a subsample of
that data set to look at if you're
interested in that information it'll
tell you the min the max for date time
and it does this for all these different
types of
data formats
what's really cool for date time is if
you do have a mixture of formats
it will give you an entire list of those
formats
and give give you that output so we are
kind of like the rest of our library we
try and automate all the processes right
so we try and automatically determine
the date time format that exists in each
column
obviously we can't cover them all
because it's too expensive but um we do
have a list of maybe like 15 to 20
formats of date time i'd have to look
exactly to remember what it is but
to give that output essentially
and of course um
so data type representation is basically
saying uh we look at like the primitive
data types within python date time and
float string we don't do like objects
essentially we would probably
characterize that in string as our case
to be able to profile it itself
um
but we're going to tell you what it
could be represented as so it's
basically saying this data set could not
be represented as an integer
it could not be represented as a float
we can convert it all of the pieces all
the elements in this row to a date time
and we can obviously you know anything
can be converted to a string ultimately
so that's always going to be one but if
it's any one of these
um
we're going to let you know essentially
and so we do this for all of the
different uh columns within the data set
so we just have a full list on top of
that global information that we've given
you
and i don't want to harp too much on
this because
we could spend hours
investigating the report itself
but i want to keep going just to show
you more aspects of the library
i may have reran that but pretty is just
trying to make it a little bit more
user-friendly to read
so
like aspects where uh potentially you
have a super large matrix obviously this
isn't that big we're going to shorten
the information around that you can see
here
just a little
side note here you can see we loaded it
as a panda's data frame up here and it's
going to tell you actually it wasn't
from a file uh it was actually from a
class within python and it was a pandas
data frame so we're able to give you
that information
but yeah pretty is essentially just
trying to make the information a bit
more compact and readable within a
terminal
um profiler type so i talked about the
fact that you can do structured and
unstructured um
obviously the data set we're working
with is structured data but
it's possible if you have a structured
data set maybe you don't want to read it
as a structured data set and you want to
read it as unstructured so we give the
user the option to read those files if
they want to in
by or to profile those files with
whatever mechanism they choose to so if
they want to profile it as an
unstructured data set you could
technically flip this profiler type to
unstructured and do so
so this is just going to give us the
same information out so we don't need to
dive into that
too much um
but like like i also said before uh
profiler options so essentially we're
able to customize the report or
customize the information
in this case you would generate
essentially a class called profiler
options and then you can set whether
those features are enabled or disabled
within the class itself
some of these will have more complex
settings that you can have for instance
we will go into how to configure and set
up a data labeler for your profile
profiler rather than using the default
data labeler
but uh
ultimately we want you to be able to
customize it however you need to
if data labeling is super expensive you
could turn it off or in this case we
want to
limit the data labeler to a maximum
sample size so like for labeling
it is computationally expensive so we
don't want to waste all our processing
if we have a file that's you know
hundreds of megabytes or a gigabyte size
file so we're going to allow you to say
instead of sampling the whole file or
sampling
um
even i mean we essentially we just want
to give you the customizability to you
know
give whatever computing car or set
whatever computing cost you want to when
you're doing profiling so it doesn't
take an extremely long time
and so we can do that as we've done here
um and so this is a different data set
the diamond data set it had
around 11 almost 11 000 samples that
were found in the file 10 columns oh
sorry excuse me samples i should say we
sub sampled the data set
because you didn't specify otherwise
once it gets above a certain size we'll
subsample it by 20
um
and so the original data set had almost
54 000 rows and we subsampled it to
around 11 000.
we did find a unique
uh
we did find duplicate rows within this
data set and we marked that out here
and then we just have other interesting
bits of information that you can look at
but the interesting part is we turned
off different aspects of the library
like the histogram or
in profiling so none of these columns
ultimately would be profiled as an
integer or get integer statistics it
would anything that looks like an
integer would ultimately get profiled as
a float instead
um and now we like
that stuff is you know like okay you
know this seems pretty straightforward
um but this is where it's going to get a
little bit more exciting um
let's say your data set's really large
right
um or you don't have all the data set at
once maybe you're getting your data set
in as a stream uh we allow you to
update your profile on demand as you
need to
so you can grab part of your data set if
it's really big or if it's coming into
the stream sample by sample you can
update that profile and it will update
the information so all of the statistics
that we've tr we try to provide you
we've tried to uh implement these
algorithms in a way that they handle
batch profiling or online we're trying
to use online
algorithms essentially so that way
the statistics are as accurate as
possible
despite you not necessarily providing it
the whole data set at one time
and so here all we did was uh
load one data set we profiled it we
grabbed a new data set
and then all we did was call update the
profile with that new data set and so we
could look at the the new profile
essentially uh describing it which is a
combination
of both of these data sets and so as a
here's what one data set looks like
here's what the other one looked like
and you can see the combination of them
we see we now have 18 samples uh both of
them had three columns and of course
there have to be some schema matching
right like we can't just update a
profile if the schemas are not congruent
um
so
uh there that is one stipulation on the
profile uh when you're doing uh when
you're when you are updating it but um
we are able to do it which is really
cool um and just a simple extension of
updating the profile being able to
update in batches
is merging it right um
so we've made this really simple for you
as well uh you can take that same data
set instead of updating the profile it's
just a simple addition um and so it's as
as opposed to
altering the original profile of either
one
you could now essentially do like a map
reduce where you could split a data set
into a ton of tiny components
and then just reduce it back together
into the original profile
and so we can look at that and we can
see we're getting the same results out
essentially
and the same information out that we
would if we updated the profile or the
same information we'd get essentially if
we just loaded the both of those data
sets together
[Music]
and then another final cool part about
this and i had harped on this a little
bit was differences in data
for us as modelers it's really important
for us to be able to understand what's
happening in the data sets we're
training a model with or understanding
the information about the data sets
we're validating a model with so that's
what we're trying to do here we're
trying to give us insight essentially
into what's happening in the original
data set that we trained with what's
happening in the data set uh
that we're doing our validation and if
there's an issue between them you know
if we're not getting the results we're
expecting in that validation data set we
can use these differences essentially to
tease that information out we can bring
that to light to see what's going on and
so
it's going to go through all the
different aspects of
all the different aspects of this or all
these different statistics that we
described in the library and it's going
to talk you know it's going to give you
simple information about unchanged or
changed um but it's also going to go
into a little bit more detail depending
on what the information it's describing
i'm going to scroll past some of this to
try and get to that um
if it's numerical columns right we're
going to give you a t-test uh we're
going to tell you uh how similar each
column provided the column you know once
again we require schema matching for
this um but we're going to tell you you
know column and data set one versus
column and data set too what what is the
likelihood that you know they're drawn
from the same distribution right um
or
uh you know we have statistics i'm
trying to see if i can scroll here to
find some
um
we'll look at the min and the mean and
the median and so
i guess the data set that we're dealing
with
was
extremely similar so that's why we're
getting everything to be pretty much
unchanged
could have chosen a data set that was a
bit more different so it'd be more
visible to see what's going on
but ultimately we're going to give you
those changes of information about the
data sets so you could you know draw
analysis on you know what might be
happening or if you you know have a data
set that's coming in as a stream right
you could you could log profiles of each
of these data sets over time to see
how your data is drifting and how that
data drift could be essentially
affecting your model in the long run
and hopefully at some point you know
based on the way the data is drifting
make a prediction whether the model
needs to be updated or changed over time
um or whether the model will still
perform well based on the alterations of
the data set over time and so you can
track those changes
and then the last cool feature that we
give you besides saving and loading your
profile of course
we wanted to give users the ability
directly to be able to graph information
and this part of the library is still
being built out obviously we love
contributors
but
the first plot here is a missing values
matrix
and so it's basically just a bar chart
we're going to give you
we're going to show you where in the
data set normal values existed
you can see here we have two different
types of mill types
this green one only existed in one
location
and it's just a bunch of spaces
you can see it happen in the comment
section no surprise there
but where there's blue here uh data is
filled in where there's orange we can
see it's just empty it's just an empty
uh
a null just nothing no information there
um but it's nice because visually you
can see the comparison between columns
to see uh you know what data is going to
be coming in similarly or what data
maybe is duplicate a duplicate column of
the other data set um and so we can make
those investigations uh and potentially
even determine you know if you know
between locale and uh
the locale abbreviation here we could
see if you know looking at this maybe
there's some alteration or human error
that occurred uh based on where we see
those null values
in existence
and then of course
histograms are really important so any
numerical column that we find within the
data set we will automatically
give you a histogram if you were to call
our plot instagram we do allow you for
each of these to specify what columns to
utilize
when you generate these plots you can
put those plots into
a figure that you've already created
that's awesome roger roger just said
already shared my first report with the
team solid tool we're going to be
getting good knowledge out of it i
really hope so
please continue to give us feedback
and report any issues you find we are
active on this project and want to stay
active and love contributors so really
happy to hear that information
um that's why we built it and open
sourced it because we see the good in
this product and we want to make sure we
can give that to everyone else as well
it's a labor of love for sure
yeah so generated
you can generate these graphs
and you can save the graphs or plot them
and ultimately we want to coalesce this
all both the uh the json report and
these figures we want to be able to put
them into an html report so if you're
getting excited about this and you want
to contribute please do we'd love to get
you started and help us out on this
product because we think it can go you
know really far in terms of the utility
um
and then
final main feature here uh saving and
loading a profile right uh you know just
generating the report um
is great but maybe you want to hold that
snapshot uh or move that snapshot around
and you want to update that snapshot at
a later time so of course saving the
profile and loading the profile is
extremely important so we give you that
feature as well ultimately and so this
is just
saving it and reloading it
just to show you that it's pretty giving
you the exact same stuff as it did
originally
i don't know if we want to look at all
this text here that's not a super
exciting um but the feature is there so
you can share profiles in fact
something that
you know we've thought about is having
you know a data zoo with profiles right
so a data scientist can go through and
see what data sets and the information
about the data sets without having to go
and do the investigation themselves
so we're working on that
uh austin do you want to answer oh
austin is on top of it thank you
um
[Music]
so
that concludes the structured profile
we're gonna about to get into
unstructured at the moment uh obviously
we're getting some questions we'd love
to field more we only have 30 minutes
and there's still the hot topic of data
labeling left and i really want to get
into that because it's super exciting
um
but definitely want to field questions
while we keep going
[Music]
okay
um
all right so keep keep putting the
questions in chat while we're going um
unstructured profile report uh
ultimately here
this is
a newer aspect of the library as well
we've really built out the structured
aspect of it we would love help and
insight so if you have statistics that
you're interested in unstructured
profiling outside of what we've done
please provide feedback please
contribute uh we would love to have some
help on this um but it's similar idea
right we have a global stats information
about the entire file and then we go
into a little bit more nitty gritty
detail about the text itself um so we
talk about entities we talk about uh the
characters that exist the words that we
find based on you know separators that
were chosen uh separated being like
spaces or commas or stuff like that um
so
trying to chunk the words together to
give you an information about the words
that exist
um
and then of course data labeling which
is probably the hottest part of
unstructured profiling is to know what
sort of text exists within there and our
focus of course has been on uh sensitive
data um so we're gonna jump into this
real quick that's the repo
um so i'm gonna hop over to the
unstructured oh it's probably at the top
give me one second
thank you
so unstructured profilers similar thing
um that we're hitting on so i'm just
going to run this and load this real
quick we grabbed a random discussion
from reddit
and all we're going to do is grab that
discussion and this is going to give you
a high level
uh high level information about what we
find in that so we talk about
when we talk about entities and data
labeling we're talking about the types
of
text or natural language processing
model is finding within it unknown is
just basically saying it's generic text
we don't care about it it's like you
know the they could be stop words um
it could just you know it's it's
basically the filler text that's not
providing the information that you know
is necessary it could be just random
adjectives and stuff like that
um but we tell you about integers
ordinal uh information some of this is
non-sensitive that we're looking at
right now quantity uh what we're um
so we're finding you know uh someone's
talking about maybe maybe they're
talking about some recipe or something
but we we found obviously people's names
in here we found addresses within this
um dates u.s states um ban stands for
bank account number i'm not 100 positive
that would be accurate uh
banking out number is actually a very
wide field of numbers um so it's it's
likely to assume that those would be
false positives
but it's possible also to exist
obviously urls people are making lots of
links with reddit uh email addresses um
and we have a lot more labels that we
can look at um
and so we identify those we talk about
it and if in it currently in the
unstructured we won't tell you the
location but if you use the labeler
directly we will tell you where in that
text that information exists which is
really cool
um and then it's going to talk about i'm
going to scroll down a little bit it's
giving you a bunch of information
telling you how long it took to do the
processing it'll give you all uh the
character informations that it found
within there uh so if you need to build
like for your unstructured model if you
need to build an encoder we're gonna try
and you know help you do that
essentially obviously there are programs
that exist that help you do that
automatically we're just another tool to
give you that information as well
so like that like i said before um you
can load a csv
and just switch it unstructured and read
that data set as unstructured as opposed
to a structured data set
um so we're giving you that option to
read the data however you want to
of course you don't have to use the
dp.profiler you could actually
technically use dp dot unstructured
profiler as well and not have to specify
the profiler type um but this just gives
you direct access to the original
profiler to give you that utility
and of course you can specify the report
out essentially and it's going to give
you the same information about what we
see and of course computational
uh cost is important to us so we're
going to give you the same options uh
you can change the stop words that it
finds in here
so
you can alter essentially
what it's removing from its
word list that it's grabbing so it's
going to try and grab all the words and
give you the count of words within it
especially if you're trying to do some
sort of tokenization for your model
um and then we want to apply the same
principles the cool principle of
updating your profile right
we want you to be able to you know
stream your data in batches we want you
know if it's an online profile you know
you're getting text as it comes in like
through an api log and you want to track
the information that's going through
your ap through
when logging your api we want that
ability to be
uh there for you so that way it's not a
profile that's one and done that's a
profile that can grow
and you're going to see we can save that
profile and load it later so
and you can update that profile
continuously as you need to and so it's
just getting all that information here
again merging profiles if we can do
batches why can't we do merge super
large text file break it into pieces if
you want to
get all the different profiles simple
addition here to reduce that information
into a single profile without altering
the original profiles we're going to
give you that ability which is really
cool
um and then like i said i want to get
into labeling so i'm kind of going
through this really quickly because i
know we don't have as much time but we
do give you like i said the ability to
save and load profiles and i don't want
to go into this too much i think it's
you know obvious uh what we're trying to
do here load the data profile it save it
reload it give us a printout you know
this means you could send the profile to
someone else or you could send the
report if you want in a serialized form
whatever you need to do
we just want to give you that
flexibility to work with that
information here
[Music]
yeah uh are there any questions that we
have on structured or unstructured
profiling that we can get into i know
austin's been answering them as we go
but i love to field more as we continue
on
um
[Music]
is that a question i heard someone speak
up for a second
okay
i will continue on so um this is
gonna be my favorite part of the library
uh it's really neat um we've tried to
basically abstract the library in a way
where any user can incorporate any
preprocessor they want to to handle text
to feed into a model they can swap out
the model however they want to if they
have their own model they can swap their
own model in as long as they set up the
correct preprocessor to handle the text
you can also handle post-processing as
well that's swappable so these are the
three main components um definitely can
build on this to even make it more
modular
but we want all of our components of our
library to be modular so you can swap
out anything as you need to
and what we're going to see here is
um
like the original the other aspects
library we try to make this super simple
load your data set
label your data set
or sorry load your data set load a
labeler
and just get predictions and print the
predictions and so you can see here
we're working with a structured data set
we got a csv here
and presumably it looks like uh this
this uh table here and the labeler is
going to give you an output of each of
the columns essentially or each of the
each of the points within this data set
and tell you whether you know it looks
like a time or it looks like someone's
phone number it looks like it starts
security
so we're going to give that information
to you
um and again same thing for unstructured
and this is the neat part is since we do
we built our model we have a paper on
this so if you're really interested in
that we can certainly link that to you
we've built an incredible synthetic data
generator to help train this model
our synthetic
repository to generate this model
essentially
and it allows us because we're doing
character level identification we can
identify identify where in the text even
potentially with if it was you know um
put within
within a word itself it's possible for
us to technically identify uh entities
or labels within that text
and so you can see here we're pulling
out things like email or date or url in
this example and it will tell you the
location of where it is in that text
we allow you to
bring your own labels and your own data
so let's say you don't want to bring
your own model and you don't want to
handle any pre-processing and you just
like what we have fine
um we're going to give you the ability
to transfer learn take your data set
with our
with our original learning or the
original model that we build and learn
on top of that to help speed up your
training so maybe you can use less data
to get that or you can reset the weights
and start from scratch whatever you want
to and of course we give you the
customizability to you know affect
whether you know change the number of
epochs validation split etc
and of course we want you to be able to
save and share the labeler right
so if you build a labeler and you want
to either reuse it in the future or
share it with someone else to utilize
like
let's go with this scenario right i'm in
company a i have a data set that i can't
share with company b
so but i could share the model
potentially
so i train my labeler on data set that i
can't share but the other company needs
to be able to identify that data if it
were to exist
so i can create a labeler as company a
save that labeler and share it with
company b so that way they can still
identify it without actually sharing the
original data sets
um
into the demo
jump here
right so preprocessor model post
processor
uh start off of course with structured
prediction we'll look at what that
originally looks like
it's just a tabular data set with a
bunch of
pseudo-random information
and what we see here is it's going to
identify uh
the labels of each of the columns
and so we can see this is just a list of
all the labels that we currently
identify
um and this is how we map those labels
to indexes based on what the model is
specifying it's not super important
but we can ultimately get this list of
predictions of what it ultimately thinks
the uh original data set
is how it's represented so representing
you know an integer uh it didn't recogni
like we don't do companies or
uh places essentially so it's saying you
know it's unknown generic text it
represented the zip um as an integer
potentially and there are cases where
it'll represent it either as an integer
or uh
an address um depending on the data set
we're working with so it might give you
that information and predictions of
course they're going to give you uh the
highest confidence but you could
technically look at the confidence of
the model with each prediction so it's
possible like for instance the zip code
right the model is actually probably
saying underneath this looks like both
an integer and it looks like an address
um
but you know it's more more of it looked
like in just an integer itself and so
that's why it gave the confidence of
that a little bit higher but you could
look at that information and say it
actually might be both of these
and that's how you could potentially
determine its zip code
and so you can see those confidences
and then i'm just have this little
helper function to help us make things a
little bit cleaner when we make it more
readable
and let this model do some processing
and so we can see here uh
the profiler itself is just doing
labeling and you can find that within
the data set um and so it's labeling and
this is we just pulled out a sample this
is integer this is unknown uh it's
grabbing some integers here
um
and it's obviously notating this as url
url and some of this like is really easy
in terms of like you could sure you
could build a regex to do this but
there's more complicated things like
addresses or people's names
um or like the overlaps you can end up
having in like social security numbers
and other numbers that you might have
that like driver's license and social
security number there's there's overlap
between those um and so making the
determination between those
our model is uh
that's the the reason we built something
uh
that's uh
neural network based or ml based is to
be able to help uh with those
predictions that are a bit more
complicated than something that's
rejects based where you have to know and
you know institute the rules that which
may or may not be 100 correct
um and so we can do the same thing here
with this unstructured prediction
we can load an unstructured labeler we
can predict data with that text uh this
is just giving you a character output so
it's telling you each character it found
within that text what entity it's
mapping to so when i talked about that
label mapping which was just
a dictionary of keys and values where
the key was the label name and the value
was integer this is essentially what we
do to determine uh
we can map these integers technically
back out to tell you what the
representation of where it existed in
this text
and so i'm going to do that real quick
and then here's just a subset um you can
see it it it's not a hundred percent uh
and so things like carrots we might have
to do some a little bit extra
post-processing but it's able to grab
email addresses or it's able to grab you
know date time
um it is able to grab you know someone's
name here
um it's able to grab uh
i guess we got another name here
but this is just a subset you know it's
someone's phone number essentially uh
these seem
uh generically obvious but
there is many cases where the data is
not represented in the format that we
would expect it to come in as and
the whole point of this model is to be
able to have that adaptability to handle
those cases
and of course like we said we want you
to be able to train the labeler from
scratch
um
so what we can do here essentially is
bring in our own data set right and then
use this function dp.train structured
labeler we can specify the labeler it's
going to
uh grab this data set and assume that
the column names are the labels that you
want them to be specify which one you
want to it to ultimately default as
train it for 10 epochs and then you can
predict with that or what you can do is
in the profiler i had mentioned this
before but
uh the options we give you the option to
say when i'm doing profiling i want to
use this labeler i just created instead
and profile with that so any data set
you put into there it's now going to use
your new labels now i didn't do the
greatest training here right um so it's
not going to be perfectly ideal uh but
you can see it's do it you know
it is able to now make predictions using
your new labels that you chose of course
you know like
the testing in
uh the test data set is almost exact to
the training data set so the model is
probably going to do very well um so
this is kind of a
a very simple rudimentary example but
the thing is we're giving you that
ability to swap out those labels we give
you also the ability to extend labels
let's say you like our labels that we
have you can add labels to the model and
you just need to continue training with
that um
as you train with new data of course it
could you know reduce the accuracy of
the labels that already exist
potentially if you're not also training
with that data as well
but you can bring in your own data to
add new labels if you want to
this is just another way of
changing the options is you can if it's
saved to a directory as opposed to you
know using the object in memory you
could you know specify the path to the
label or to the model so if someone
shares with you the model right um you
can then just specify the path and load
it that way if you want to
we talked about transfer learning that's
where we just add labels on to the
existing
and so we're just going to add these new
labels here
and train the data set with the with
those extra labels that we've just added
in here and you can see it's not doing
the greatest of course we don't not
using a lot of data um that's not intent
of you know this demo is to show you a
perfect result here all right the intent
of this demo is to show you you can do
this and you can get your model to a
state where it's making those
predictions
i guess the uh the results here didn't
have the
original data set so that didn't work
out unfortunately
oh wait here they are i just had to
scroll look at that um
so original data set had uh we had those
three and we did evaluation on that and
you can see you know it's not performing
the greatest we didn't train very much
um so in in the original model was
trained on hundreds of thousands of
samples so you would need a lot more
samples to be able to get to that point
but it is possible to just add labels on
to the end of the existing labeler and
and be able to
uh
use those predictions as well as the
ones with your new labels as well
and
of course saving and loading it so you
can share labelers
and then you can completely build a
label there from the ground up you can
swap out the process like i said you can
write your own preprocessor you can add
to our library and include more
preprocessors we obviously have default
ones we have a whole regex one there is
a full example in this notebook where
you can build a regex labeler from
scratch so add your own regex
if you want to use your own regis model
and use that inside of the profiler to
give you that ability
um
but you can swap out the preprocessor
you can swap out the model for it if you
want to swap out the post processor and
then we have a rudimentary uh ability to
be able to check the pipeline just to do
a validation it would give you an
insertion error if there was a problem
uh the other neat feature is when you're
dealing with our labeler we give you
help functions right we want you to know
what parameters you can alter in the
model or what parameters you can alter
in the preprocessor or post processor so
that way you can set up the options just
like anything else like profiler options
like the data reader options you really
want the customizability there for you
to be able to do that
and so that's ultimately what we're
doing here
we've basically built this three
component library it's a data reader
it's a profiler and it's the labeler
all of them abstracted enough from each
other that you could use each one
independently obviously you need to load
the data in somehow so hopefully you use
our data class
before you put it into the labeler
before you put it into the profiler but
you can take these components and
harvest them and reuse them however you
want to
or take these components and dice them
up and use your own components that you
have
ultimately built this library for us but
also
for others because we see the valid
appointment
i don't think we're going to have enough
time for
the final
demo because i would love to field more
questions
but uh ultimately like i said you have
the ability to create your own model and
that's all this is doing just so you can
see
um
we're taking a character level lstm
model specifying all the parameters um
telling you how to validate uh basically
so that you the valid parameter is
essentially just you know telling the
the model or telling the class
essentially you know what sort of
parameters like what the format has to
be in to be able to accept them but
how to construct the model this is where
you're actually putting in the model
and this is one way to do it we want to
also add like a class like if you
already built a model uh in
in tensorflow just to be not to even
have to write the class we want you to
be able to eventually just be able to
load that model itself directly into a
class like a like a model loading
labeler
that way you can just load that in and
directly insert it for prediction
however you want to
ultimately like i said you can create a
new model add it in add your post pre
and post processors
um specify the options turn things on or
off
um and make predictions with that but
yeah i know i jumped through that really
quickly we have nine minutes for
questions
um this is just the example of showing
you how to create that but um
i'm gonna pause there
[Music]
from brian is there a profile to sql
schema sort of thing
um
we don't have that at the moment
but if you want to throw up a github
issue that's
probably doable
it's a very valid ad
like i said we do
convert to a serializable json format so
it'd be very easy to just
dump that
into a database if need be
i know we have within capital one
someone they're they're tracking this
stuff but i think they're dumping it
into an sql database but um
they wrote their own functions for that
yeah
when you compare profiles is it possible
to set the sensitivity
also switch between relative and
absolute difference
um
we i don't believe we can set the
sensitivity at the moment nor can we
switch the relative versus absolute
difference
but that is a good
question
so you talk about like percent
differences
i'm assuming
so one thing i would say about this is
currently
um
[Music]
we don't
uh
we're basically giving you values out in
terms of the in terms of the differences
um
we're not being it we're not acting
currently this is something we also want
to add a library acting as a validator
to say this was a big enough difference
so typically we'll say unchanged or tell
you the value it is changed by
um
i'm curious the thoughts on absolute
differences in what you're like what
fields you're thinking about uh and what
stats you would be thinking about in
terms of absolute differences when we do
things like t-tests we try and give you
all the information like degrees of
freedom that we determine and stuff like
that so that way if you need to redo the
calculation yourself or use
um a different confidence interval to
you know determine
uh whether it's statistically
significant
uh you can do that we're just giving you
uh we we're just trying to give you the
information data so that way you can
make that final decision and be the
validator yourself not to say we don't
want to become a validator and have that
as a component of our library
that's a very good question thank you
erica
uh lucas asked how do you plan to scale
out of memory data sets um so right now
we actually
um
we do like have uh the way it's kind of
deployed internally
is it spins up in a bunch of docker
containers and then loads the data
um in segments and then it'll merge the
profiles together at the end
so
that's kind of the way we built it so
you can
scale at will
save the profiles at some location wait
till the jobs are done and then merge
them
i'll stay on for another few minutes but
i just want to say i really appreciate
everybody who attended
thank you for your time